Thank you. Thank you, Natasha,
for you.
I mean,
that's the stance you take when you're
getting a cape, but I don't want to be,
you know, rude. Did not have to worry.
Thank you. And I want you to know,
thanks to Natasha and also, um, I
typically wear my Cape on the inside.
So if you don't have a cape on the
outside, you can keep it on the inside.
Am I amplified and ready to
rock and roll? Yes. Yeah. Okay.
So what we're going to do today is we're
going to test the limits of what is
probable,
what is profitable,
and what is possible when we bring
our imagination to the workspace.
When we bring our
imagination to our homes,
when we bring our
imagination to the streets,
when we bring our imagination
to a talks at Google. What?
So instead of starting at the beginning,
we're going to start at the ending.
So please stand up.
Yeah.
Okay.
On the count of three,
you are going to give yourselves and
each other the best standing ovation you
have in u one, two, three.
Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Um, you can
sit down physically bluebuds
stay standing emotionally
for the whole time.
So I want you to remember that you know,
all of us here have and will dare to
share our wildest ideas and we'll be a
little scared or we will deign to raise
our hands and it all hands meeting and
share an idea that
scares us or we might be,
it's taking the stage and
giving a presentation and
were a little freaked out.
And so you can remember this moment when
we all gave each other and ourselves a
standing ovation and you can
take that with you. Okay.
So I have spent the last 10 years
consciously bringing creativity into the
workspace and imagination.
And I'm talking about when I've worked
and before that little less consciously,
um, hadn't really developed this
idea of creative trespassing.
But when I was bagging groceries,
when I worked as a Barista,
when I worked in a museum, when
I worked in technology, um,
and as I got more conscious about this,
you know,
infusing imagination and creativity,
I started to notice two things
that were really astounding to me.
And the first thing is,
is that we don't need to work in a job
or a field that is uniquely creative in
order to be uniquely
creative within our work.
And the second thing that I learned is
that if we bring imagination to confront,
like are self limiting
beliefs, uh, obstacles,
everyday challenges that we will
experience unlimited solutions,
ideas and innovations. True
Story News at 10, I'm done.
Um, and that's what compelled me to
write this book, creative trespassing,
which I'll show you. Oh my gosh, it's
so red and white and fantastic. Sure.
Okay. And so what I want to, my
talk today is really about, um,
some moments or stories where I learned
to see myself limits as opportunities
to,
to creatively trespass,
to maybe add something that wasn't
there and in live in not just myself,
but colleagues and the mission and vision
of the companies that I worked for.
So anybody here go to
contemporary art museums? Okay.
About 50%. And somebody was like, man,
not only fits a free day, that's fine,
that's fine.
I sort of felt like math when somebody
offered me a job in a contemporary art
museum. I'm like, I don't
understand the rules.
They're always saying like don't touch
things. And then it's contemporary art.
So they're like, why aren't you
touching it? Very confusing.
And I,
they wanted somebody like a rule breaker
from the outside to come inside and
create like wild programs and generate
new revenue streams and increase
attendance. Pretty regular
metrics for functioning. Right?
And so I got there and I started, I
did what I, I'm I do in, in theater.
That's my background. You sort of
assess the situation and you're like,
who's my audience? What do I have to
work with? What are the props? And, um,
I realized there was this weird thing
I'd never heard of called employee of the
month. Anybody familiar with it?
And I'm like, employee of the month.
That sounds fantastic. How
do I win that? And right.
You're laughing again. Hr was like,
Tonya, you don't win it. You earn it.
And I was like,
then I will earn your vote and when it,
and here's what happened,
I'll show you.
Uh, so we, we, um,
the program I created was called out
of the cubicle cause I was like, um,
they put me, they brought me
in to think outside of the box.
They stuffed me in a cubicle.
Ironic or scary, it's a fine line.
And I decided to,
um,
to create a programmatic area online
where people could see that, um,
those of us who thought museums
are kind of sterile in the rules,
I don't understand and am I, am I, you
know, okay to go in, will I fit in? Um,
I created this program where I ran around
the offices and actually got to know
my colleagues and made these videos
that expose the fact that art museums,
just like any other office culture
are unique and boring and exciting and
everything in between. And
so people started watching
this program, um, you know,
they came in through the United
States than other countries.
And so I was doing my job essentially.
Um,
but here's the critique that people had.
Museum board and this was a
corporately structured museum.
They were probably 200 employees.
And, um, there were lots of rules.
And I said working in fun,
they're not mutually exclusive.
And then I showed them why they're not.
So I did launch programs in the museum.
That was part of my job.
I increased revenue streams. So not only
did people come in through the videos,
but they literally wanted to come and
see what was happening in the museum.
I also created a program
called arm wrestling for art.
Crazy where I use my teeny tiny nonprofit
budget to buy an arm wrestling table
cause that makes sense.
And then we put it in the middle of the
museum because the problem I was trying
to solve was who here likes art?
Who here can afford to buy the art that
they really like? All the hands go down.
And I thought, how do we
democratize the acquiring of art?
How do we make art accessible for
everyone? Um, what do museums not do?
They don't give away art.
And so I thought,
let's make people sweat it out and
arm wrestle for a piece of art.
That seems fair.
That's how we'd solve the problem as kids.
That's how we're going to do it as adults.
So we increased attendance numbers.
That's my job.
Brand awareness.
Everybody started to know about
Scottsdale Museum of Contemporary Art.
It's a small contemporary art museum,
but it has all of this like new life
and people coming through the doors and
through the videos, um, earned media,
which anybody in marketing knows is
you pay a lot and then you're like, oh,
that didn't have an impact.
We didn't go viral. Okay. Um,
so we just earn it the old fashioned way.
And then you dropped the mic.
Okay. Let's see. So, um,
once upon a time I was giving a talk at a,
uh,
a startup week and these
two engineers from, uh,
American Express came up to me after
my talk. They're all like, oh my God,
that was so cool and creativity in
blah, blah, blah. And they're like, oh,
we want to start an
innovation lab in our company,
but we have no buy in from
our boss. No money, no space.
And nobody thinks it's a good,
what's your solve Tanya?
Oh my gosh. Uh, I'm like totally easy.
I'm going to introduce you to
an artist named meg. Do Good.
So meg lives in Chicago.
She had a dream.
Her dream was to have four walls,
a gallery space. That's it.
She wanted four walls to be able to
put people's artwork in from around the
world. She had no money. She was like a
full time artist, no patrons, no space,
no by and no American Express card.
I'm certain.
And here's what she did to
solve that problem. So her,
she didn't have the limiting belief
that the guys at American Express had.
So she created clutch gallery.
It's a 25 square inch space
in the heart of her purse.
No,
it's totally absurd. And
whackamole wonderful. Right?
And so she solved a problem and I'll
show you one of her installations.
It's a painting show.
And so it just goes to show you that this,
you know,
had she had the same limiting belief, like
I don't have money, I don't have space,
I don't have buyin, she never would
have created this innovative space.
And artists love the challenge of trying
to create artwork for 25 by 25 square
inches.
Okay.
I know. Okay. So who
here went to first grade?
Great. I knew we'd have something in
common. Uh, so I went to first grade,
I was five years old,
which was younger than the kids,
not because I was real smart,
but because my parents had sex at a
certain period of time and I was born in
September, so there was
no, like, she's so smart.
So I was younger than the other kids
and I was like, I was Super Chubby,
but it was all focused in my belly.
So it was like I had a gut, you know,
and I wore eyeglasses and anybody
wear eyeglasses as a four or five,
six year old. Fantastic. We
thought we were really cool. Okay.
My Mom said you're cute,
Tanya.
I felt sophisticated and more
intellectual than my counterparts.
I was ready to rock.
So I get on the school bus for the
first day of first grade and I'm like,
I'm looking good. What? And I've got
my glasses and I'm just rock and roll,
you know, like, ah. Um, but there didn't
seem to be any like early adopters of me.
That's fine.
And so I get on,
I get on the bus and I see a girl who's
about my age and the bus is about to
take off.
So I slide into one of those pleather
benches and sit next to her and I'm like,
let the day begin. And she looks
me square in the eye and I'm like,
I like this assertiveness,
you know?
And she's like four eyes.
I know.
So every single day of the first week of
school I'd get on the bus and I try to
like avoid the child tyrant,
you know,
I'd find like a seat over here and somehow
that little menace managed to sneak
in and call me four eyes.
And I was like, hmm,
sad and lonely and didn't know what to do.
So I consulted my mom and my mom was like,
Tanya,
four eyes are better than two.
And I'm like, not only does
that little girl suck at math,
but she sucks at life. And
so I was like, great, I'm,
I'm armed and I'm ready to rock and roll.
And so I get on the bus with my newfound
trays and I like sit next to her on
purpose and she's like our eyes and I'm
like, four eyes are better than two.
And she said, no, they're not. And I said,
nothing. I had no comeback
at all. The good news is,
is that I grew up and oh,
somebody,
I was talking about this story the
other day and somebody is like,
what happened to this little girl?
And I'm like, well, you know,
she didn't invent Google glass.
Okay.
And she's not a cofounder of Warby Parker.
But what I've learned over years of
being in the world is that that little
critic is not only on the outside of us,
but a lot of times we have that little
child tyrant on the inside of us.
And also what I've learned is that when
we see her or him or non gender binary
person, um, and we
acknowledge and we say, okay,
I see you and we let go. That's super
helpful. And I learned another thing too,
that nobody writes books or
plays or make software for our,
about anybody who's perfect,
right?
You wouldn't want to read a
book if everybody like fit in.
It was perfect to be perfect or
to fit in is to be invisible.
And I just didn't want to be invisible.
So that was a really good moment
for me to learn. That's me.
Stop it right now is my mom here
a little,
and I've clearly,
I was going to going to audition
for the village people the next day.
Oh my gosh. Okay. So at
some point in my career,
I,
uh,
I received a phone call from a software
company named acts so soft and they were
like, Tanya, we've seen you
performing in presenting around time.
We'd like to talk to you about
software. And I'm like, software,
that sounds awesome.
I don't know what they're talking.
I love cashmere.
Uh,
and so I took a leap of faith.
I really do,
but I can't afford it. So, but I go
to secondhand stores and purchase it.
Thank you. Okay. So, so, uh, you know,
I took a leap of faith and I decided to
meet with this software company and I
met with the CEO at the time law
Dan Show Jaya. And she's like,
we really like your energy. That's
why we brought you in. And I'm like,
I like your energy. That's
why I came in. She was like,
but we're not offering you a job.
And I'm like, okay, why am I here?
I don't understand this. And
she's like, but you know,
we've always wanted to
have a brand evangelist.
You would make a great evangelist.
And I was like,
that would totally freak
my Jewish mom out. Yeah,
I want to be an evangelist.
Can I get a witness?
And so I started work at this company
and my first day on the job I was like,
what is this magical software was selling?
Is it like a tool for telling stories?
Is it a magical paintbrush that
allows artists to make work on wall?
Like what is it? And she was like, oh,
it's a BTB project management
software for a software developer.
And I was like, Ah, trapped in
slow motion. Like what are you,
I don't understand that.
And Soon I learned, I didn't
understand a lot of stuff. You know,
I would hear people talking
about AI and I was like, oh,
that's when a British person is at
a pub and they ask for more beer.
They're like, I, I'd like another
point that's not the case. Uh,
I also heard people talking about, they
were like open source, open source,
open source. And I'm like,
don't kiss that person.
I'm pretty sure that that's no Bueno.
So I had a lot of learning
to do and unfortunately,
and fortunately within the first two
months of being there and knowing
absolutely very little about software
and my boss came to a colleague and I and
said, we are going to host
a girls in technology event.
It's an inaugural one and I
want to show up in a big way.
So come up with a big idea
around women in technology.
This is April,
2015 just to give some context.
So my colleague and I,
Sarah, we like brainstorming,
came up with nothing. Then, uh, you know,
I went for a little walk and I started
thinking about women in the tech space
and women in lots of spaces and how a
lot of times we're not seeing her or
celebrated for the superheroes we are.
And so I came up with this symbol.
I didn't come up with her. She's been
around for a long time. The bathroom lady,
she's here, she's made an appearance.
I've seen her twice today. Thank you. Uh,
and I knew that the symbol was
immediately recognizable across cultures,
across genders. And uh, I didn't
know anything else. I just had like,
it wasn't even an idea.
It was just a symbol.
And I brought the symbol back
to my colleague and I'm like,
here she is. And my colleagues like,
okay. And that was sort of that,
but I couldn't shake the fact that
see the, the shape of her dress, it's,
it's a triangle. And
I thought, Gosh, yeah,
it's dress and it looks kind
of like the shape of a cape.
And so I printed the vector and made
a few lines and then I, oh my gosh,
you're right there. And,
and then ACC, so soft,
we came up with the campaign,
it was never addressed.
And I'm gonna show you what happened
with it because I think it's important to
pay.
Let's see.
When Tanya and Sarah came to
me and they gave me their, um,
their pitch on this idea, I immediately
saw it and I thought, wow, yes,
I completely agree.
This was,
this was big initially I thought of a
symbol that was easily recognizable and I
thought if the bathroom lady,
because she's everywhere,
just everywhere in the world,
that lady gets around on.
So I've printed out an image of the
symbol and I took a pencil and started
drawing some lines and very
quickly she had a cape on and um,
she was fully present and it was as if
she'd been there this whole time and I
just hadn't seen her.
We were at the conference,
so we're pretty busy. You
know, we're on social media.
We saw the first tweet and we were
like, wow, this is great. You know,
someone is really
connecting with the image.
And then Huffington Post retweeted it.
I was kind of the beginning of it going
viral and then Bam in 24 American hours
now.
It just blew up.
I think people were very excited to to
see that they march just a symbol of the
mundane, but they're actually
a symbol of the extraordinary.
We're trying to create
a community and a forum,
so a woman with telling us about how she
had showed the image to her young son
and daughter and then later they had
gone to the restroom and the kids were
excited and they said, hey mom, we're
going into the superheroes bathroom.
I thought that's how we measure
success is the next generation.
Now they are seeing things differently
and their perceptions have been shifted.
We started having an overwhelming
request for merchandise. However,
we didn't want to commoditize
the conversations that
were taking place on it was
never addressed,
so we thought,
let's start a steamed scholarship with
Asu and we've planned on fueling that
scholarship with the motion. Nice. Tonya
was bought into ax off as an evangelist.
And part of the things that she's
phenomenal with his public speaking,
it's only natural for her to be popping
up maybe in your city soon where she
will be speaking on this campaign and
I'm helping keep the movement going.
It was never just campaign is really a
story and it's also a proposition for
other people to share their stories.
So yes,
I will be going out into the world and
speaking publicly about it was never
addressed. Um, you can
invite me to your hometown.
There's no crowd that's too small
or too large because if we see women
differently, we see the world
differently and we see women differently.
We see the world differently.
We see women differently.
Ah,
one thing that was really astounding
about this moment in terms of my work life
and my creative life merging was my job.
I was embedded in marketing.
I was an evangelist.
My job was to learn the product and to
go out into the world and preach the good
word of B2b project management software,
the end and uh,
and being presented with this challenge,
right?
Solve a problem that you really
know very little about. Uh, your,
you've been a woman in technology
for two months, do something.
And I really saw that as an opportunity
to use some of the skills that I had
developed while as a playwright in theater
school to see and engage in audience
with text, with a story. And I went
above and beyond my job, um, because it,
it was something that was important to do.
And even though I no longer
work for act so soft,
we created this beautiful thing
that's bigger than all of us together.
And something that I write about in
creative trespassing that a lot of people
forget is that we have an opportunity
to leave a creative legacy at our,
at our work.
We can leave people in processes in better
shape than when we arrived there and
took me a long time to learn that.
I mean,
I definitely had some jobs where I'm
like, you refill your own paper. Ah,
and I was out
ink cartridge,
my pie hole, you know, uh,
and then I left. Right.
And uh, and so I'm really proud of
myself. Then I left this, uh, and,
and um, and I think that that's really
important because as we sort of, you know,
conflate or,
or like we,
we remove the space between work and life
between fun and work that we actually
have all of these opportunities to create.
So I would like to do something
right now. I feel like, um,
we started at the ending. So
let's end at the beginning, right?
And after this I would love to have a
little Q and a. Slash. Conversational.
That's Italian for conversation.
So we're just going to take a moment to
close your eyes and I'm going to lead
you through a very
short minds eye journey.
If you've not done a mindsight journey,
all it means is that I will gently guide
you and you just receive. That's it.
So
I want you to imagine one of
your self limiting beliefs.
And by that I mean a belief that you
hold that stops you from having an
experiencing more joy,
more creativity,
and pursuing your dreams.
So it could be anything from,
I don't deserve a raise
two,
I can't call myself an artist
or I don't belong here.
Yeah.
So see this self limiting belief.
I want you to gently let it go.
And when you feel like you've let it go,
and this is a longer
process than through snap,
but when you've let it go for now,
I want you to open your eyes.
Okay.
And
now that you've let something go,
there's room to take a leap.
So we're going to stand up.
And uh,
this isn't a big performative gesture.
The most important part about taking
leap is that we're doing it together.
And so it's your, the bend your knees
just a little bit, just slightly. And it,
and again, it's not about jumping
highest, it's just about, yeah,
we didn't sign any waivers.
This is a gentle jump.
Um, again, the most important
part is that we do it together.
So I'm an account on the count of three,
we're going to gently take a leap
of faith together. Okay. One,
two, three. Awesome.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
See,
I see.
And, um, and also, you know,
here's something I, you know, I,
I'm,
I've,
I've worked really hard and focused to
feel comfortable in front of human beings
and presenting and even I get nervous
sometimes and I'm guessing that all of us
get nervous sometimes. And, um, we'll,
you can remember the beginning if you
need a standing ovation from all of us and
you, and you can also remember that
when you're leaping into the unknown,
when you're starting a new job,
when you're tackling a new project,
when you're sharing your ideas that
were all leaping with you. Okay.
I think that's helpful
to know. All right. Um,
I would love to engage in a little
questions and answers and if you have no
questions, I'll ask you questions, but
I don't think you're going to want that.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm totally
kidding. Uh, oh. It's like, Oh,
you're very, very intuitive. Uh,
how do you write a book?
How do you write a book?
This is actually something that I
write about and creative trespassing,
whether you're wanting to write a book
or make a career shift or actually try on
a different role,
you start
and, and so, uh, you know,
you write a few lines about what
you think the book is about.
Maybe you write a few lines about what
you want your next job to look like or
what you want your next
project to look like. Um,
and then you leave it for a day and then
you come back a day later and then you
don't look at it and you write some more.
Okay.
So this is how I've written this
book and this is how a lot of people,
authors that I know, right,
is they write a little a lot.
You know what I'm saying? And
a lot of people, if you're,
if you're thinking about,
or you already have a practice of
writing in a journal or writing a book or
whatever, a lot of times we have this a
self limiting belief that if we don't,
we put ourselves on a schedule.
And if we do not adhere to that schedule,
we will just stop game over.
Uh,
and I would suggest to you that you,
even if you mess up your own
schedule that only you gave you,
that you forgive yourself and
continue on. Okay. So do a little,
a lot. And also, um, I, I find that
accountability for me personally,
I like to have a sort of my, my personal
board of directors that I'm like,
you guys, here's what I'm doing. I
will send you some pages, would you,
I don't need you to read them. I just need
to, you need to know they're coming. Um,
or I need you to read them
and I need some feedback.
I need to Beta test these ideas. Very
keen of Beta testing lives and projects.
I love it. So yeah, that's
what, that's a little a lot.
Yeah.
Thanks Kate.
I was curious about when you were saying
you were getting criticism around, oh,
she's just running around and having
fun and how you felt about that,
whether you were just like blew it off
because you have all of that check all
those checkboxes of I'm so great.
Or did that feel bad to you?
I was curious what you felt. That's a
great question. Um, all of the above.
And I remember actually when that news
was delivered, we were in a, um, uh,
an all hands meeting for just the museum
staff and there were like 20 of us
there and my boss sort of
delivered the news of like,
there are people who are really concerned
who find this you problematic. Um,
and he's like, and I want you
to know I got your back. Right?
And then I made a realization
cause it hurt. I mean, human
beings, right? You know,
when somebody says,
Hey,
all the effort that you're putting
into making this organization better,
um, is not right. You are not doing
it the right way. I felt hurt.
I felt like, oh my gosh, how do I control,
this is the only way I know how
to contribute. And La, la La,
it was great that my boss had my back.
Um, and I also learned something that was,
that that was freaky and unexpected,
which was the joy is actually really
confrontational to people who are not
choosing to live within a state of joy.
And that was both disheartening and
really powerful information. Uh,
yeah. So that's why I sort of
preached the good word of joy, uh,
because it is a mindset and it's
something we can choose even even in rigid
rule-bound environments.
It's really the only thing that we have.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Um, so how do you deal with the
perception if you've received this,
that when you switch projects that people
might think that you're unreliable or,
um, flighty or unfocused?
How do you deal with,
I wrote an entire book all about that. I'm
not, I'm not, I'm being totally sincere.
So for years people would
say, so what do you do? Uh,
and I was like, I am curator of
everything, you know, whatever.
I just made stuff up until I realized
that if I assessed my skills,
my superpowers,
and understood what those were,
then it opened up everything that any,
I could go into any field, any job.
So the clarity comes in knowing what
you're bringing because you bring that to
whatever situation,
you bring that to the supermarket,
you bring that to your family parties,
you bring that to to work.
So the sooner I understood what I brought,
the easier it was for me to leap
into different forms. And, um,
and that's something,
you know,
we obviously live in a system and a
society that's very siloed, uh, that,
you know, and we have business
cards to prove that. Right?
You are a developer. You are, you know,
and I remember I was at a conference,
I was,
I was speaking to 500 CEOs
and the CEOs here. Great.
Let the jokes rip. So I was, I was, uh,
I was, I was in the back
of the room and there were,
and there were 500 seat CIO hose,
all dressed in suits,
varying colors from dark blue to black.
And it was a Saturday.
So they didn't have to wear suits.
So you know,
they were like this and I was in the
back watching the speaker before me and I
was freaking out cause he
was talking about like AI
and I AI and Vr and I'm like,
unless they want a monologue about
like, you know, TMI or UTI or
BMW's, I had nothing. I was totally
scared. And to make matters worse,
he, he's killing it, right? You know
the, and the, the CEO's are going wild.
They're like,
and I'm like, ah, where's the exit?
And then the MC grabs the microphone
and he's like, Oh, let's thank Steve.
And then we'd like to welcome to the
stage, Tanya could Katon she is a,
Oh and I'm like, Oh
hell no, I'm not a CIO.
Another self limiting belief and
I'm not a CIO.
And then he grabs him like,
and he's like chief inspiration officer.
And I was like,
oh my God.
So what I learned from that it,
what I learned from that moment,
and I write about it
because it was so impactful,
is that I thought when people ask you,
what do you do that it meant?
What's your job title? But in that
moment I realized, Oh, it's my purpose.
That's what I do.
And,
and the more certain and
comfortable you are with that,
the more you can bring it in. And when
somebody says, what do you do? You know,
you can make up a job title. You can
tell them, here's my purpose or sit down.
I'm not going to give you
an elevator pitch. You know,
I'm good if you really want to know,
let me share what I do in the world.
So great question.
Thank you.
So for people who may not consider
themselves super creative, Yup.
Are there tools or strategies that you
advise to maybe tap into creativity?
You mentioned like when
it would be our campaign,
you've figured that out on a walk or
some kind of strategy where maybe we step
away from our day to day,
not so creative work to tap
into the creative. Absolutely.
That's a great question.
So first of all,
I would like to say that creativity is
defined as really using your imagination.
It's not about making art or painting
or Dakota. You could do that.
The creativity is about
using your imagination.
So one thing that I recommend in
creative trespassing is to ditch school.
Anybody ditch school as a kid.
Yeah,
we learned all the skills we need to
disrupt our patterns and habits that are
keeping us stuck. So what I recommend
is that you get up from your desk,
you don't have anything to prove by
working until you're sweating and you're
regretting the job you took. Okay? Nothing
to prove. Get up, take a five minute,
10 minute walk.
Um,
Stanford did a study on walking
and in the impact of creativity.
And it raises your creativity by 60%.
So when you find yourself trapped in,
you know, uh, trying to solve a
problem or just stuck in a routine,
get up and go for a walk.
And in fact,
there's something called the Museum
of walking that I'm a board member of
and it's true.
And you'll look it up.
And basically the museum
exists outside of the wall.
There are no walls to the museum.
What?
Why don't you Google that
later? Oh my God. I was praying.
I was trying to weave that in
anyway. Um, and then, and then,
and then throughout the,
um,
throughout the book I have these things
called productive disruptions and their
exercises because I know
that when we disrupt these,
these holding patterns,
we actually do more work and have more
joy in that state of creating work.
We're cocreating work. Yeah. Thank you.
This work is incredible and you are a
phenomenal speaker and I'm sure you wake
up every morning with ideas, but what's
next for you? You've written a book.
You're a public speaker. Oh my gosh. Gosh.
This is where I think my meditation
practice has messed me up.
What's next is what's now I don't,
I don't know what else to say about that.
What's next is,
is me continuing to speak.
So a lot of companies bring me in to give
talks and teach workshops on how do we
use creative skills from maybe theater
or contemporary art to innovate from
within our companies.
I would like to be doing more and more.
I could do that all day. And I think, you
know, a lot of people ask, well, you know,
you come from performance, don't you
want to perform again on a stage?
And to me the most impactful work is,
is being an outsider on the inside.
And then you quickly realize
when you're like, hey, you guys,
I'll do one of the things
is like I do too. Oh my God,
they're creative trespassers everywhere.
And so my really the end game
with creative trespassing
is to cause a creative
revolution inside our bodies,
our minds and our cubicles.
That's all. Thank you. Yeah.
Hi. Hi. Uh, with the theme
of International Women's Day
being bounced for better,
uh, can you talk about what balance means
for you? Ah, sleeping eight hours. Um,
I, you know what, so as in my
introduction, you, you learned,
I actually have gone through cancer
two times. One when I was 21,
one was when I was 31 years old.
And, um, and when you've endured a,
an illness or if you're
living with an illness, uh,
you are painfully aware of the body
and the mind and the connection or the
moments when one wants to
disconnect because it's,
it's painful and uncomfortable.
And after,
and during those two bouts of cancer,
I realized I needed to
take care of myself.
So even though I'm sort of on book tour
and I'm going back and back, and then, um,
what,
uh,
how I care for myself is I eat well and
I'm open to dinners being paid for by
anyone, then I better, uh, I eat well.
Um,
I try to walk every day and I say try
because sometimes I'm limited in time.
Um, but even then I literally will walk
around like a hotel parking lot. I,
my body feels better when it's walked.
Uh,
and also I meditate and,
um, that makes me really,
that makes me consider what's in front
of me rather than what's ahead of me.
And I think that's really important
because if I'm not occupying this space
right here and right now, I'd actually
don't know what's going to be next.
I won't be open to what's next and I
want to be open. So yeah, that's it.
Great question. Thank you.
Um, first of all, great talk.
Thank you so much for sharing
your story with us. Uh,
I do feel like you have
the answers for everything,
but I wanted to know,
did you ever at expedience self doubt
in each of your journeys and if yes,
how did you combat that? Oh yes,
all the time. And in fact, what,
just,
I'll go with the first thing that popped
into my head when I started my job at
the museum. I le, I mean I don't
have an art history background.
I've never been a curator. Like I
was the weirdest choice for that job.
And so I was freaking out the day
before and a n I combated it by saying,
what do I wear?
How do I look rd?
How do I look like I work
in a museum because my big,
my big self limiting belief, since
I was little until now, it was,
I don't fit in.
I don't belong here.
That has been a refrain in the past.
So I'm aware of that.
And so what I do is I, the same
thing I've learned in theater school,
you have to see an audience,
you have to listen to an audience,
you have to decide what you're
going to give to an audience.
And I don't mean this
in a performative way,
I mean this thing like an
interpersonal. So I'm like, okay,
they're contemporary art.
So I just sort of assessed the situation
and thought I will wear a blue shirt
and an orange blazer and red
glasses and some funky sneakers.
Yes,
I looked like a cartoon character,
but I made me feel like I was
embodying the spirit of art.
So that's what I do and I do.
And so,
and also I was recently
telling a story in front of a,
for the moth in front
of 2000 human beings.
And I hadn't done a storytelling in that
form. And I was scared, super scared.
So here's what I did in that situation,
I'm about to go on and I say to myself,
Tanya, if you pass out,
you don't have to go on
creative trespassing,
you know?
And so this is something
I've learned from one of, uh,
one of my teachers and from reading and
watching her Pema Chodron is that when
you were experiencing fear, it's sort
of the last thing on our list to do,
to like embrace it. Right? Um,
and she's like, go into it,
go into a barrel head first into
fear, and then you realize, oh,
it's not so bad. I see. I
came out on the other side.
We always come out on the
other side, you know, that.
And that's why the leap of faith is
important. The middle part, you're like,
but you always know that
you're going to land right?
And that it's going to be more than okay.
So that's what I do.
Hey.
Um,
so it's really cool to hear about how
confident you are and like your purpose
and what you bring to the table.
Um,
and you've talked about like how it's
important to be grounded in that.
How do you get to that point though,
if you could talk to them? Yeah,
that's an awesome question.
So first of all, um, the,
the way in which we write books,
the way in which we live lives,
all of it is a practice. I approach it
as a practice. I'm not the only one.
There's a practice of meditation,
a doctors practice medicine, right?
We, those who play
instruments practice. Okay?
So when we think about it as a
practice, uh, and if it's a practice,
guess what? It's never going to be
perfect, right? It's a practice.
So if we think of, of sort of building
skills around, I want to be more curious.
I want to meet more
confident as practicing.
I'm going to try on what confidence looks
like or feels like to me today. Okay.
That didn't work.
That's okay.
But one moment within that I did feel
a little confident. Then your rubber,
you then you try it again the
next day and then the next day.
And then what happens is
something I learned in theater,
which is muscle memory,
guess what?
Your body knows what to do.
It shows up without your
mind messing things up. Okay.
So you have to practice embodying
what it is you want to be,
what you and how you want to be in
the world every day a little bit.
Is that helpful?
Okay.
And I think we're going to
take two more questions. Okay.
Um,
how did you come to find your purpose
and what tools did you use and which ones
did you like most of all?
So I've,
I've written about this because
it's taken me a, you know,
lots of tools and in creative trespassing,
uh,
an exercise that I have is,
it's called write your fight song.
But really it's a manifesto. Who here
knows who manifesto is? Yeah, it's a,
it's a powerful declaration
of your purpose, of,
of your why and your how. Like, yes,
I declare this and here's how I'm going
to actually do something about it.
So it's not passive, it's
active. Uh, and so I've found my,
I say per Pi,
cause I don't think we have one purpose.
And I think that this is
also one of those systems,
silo traps we find ourselves in.
And I've definitely found myself,
like I majored in theater.
How come I can't get a job in theater?
I have no purpose and seen,
nope.
Using my degree. Um, and I,
I've often found myself in that,
in that trap. And then I realized,
Oh wait, my purpose is what?
And another indicator is what really
enlivens you when you're in the act of
doing it. Right? So if you are
coding and you're like, Holy Shit,
this is so awesome, this feels good. And
every fiber or you're a problem solver,
you're a presenter and you're like, I like
people. I like when they ask questions.
Those are all indicators
of your purpose. So, uh,
I guess by the book and do
the exercise. Um, and also,
and also, um, just know that
you monitor, you're the,
you're the conductor of
the experiment of view.
And so you can be aware of situations
where you feel like this makes me feel
alive and it enlivens those around me.
Maybe this is one of my purposes.
Yeah, great question. Thank
you. Okay. We had a super quick,
we had a creative trespasser question.
Didn't need a microphone. Love that.
How often do I burst into song?
Like in my daily life?
Oh, well I am known far and
wide as the monotone wonder.
So I don't typically, um, uh, but uh,
I burst into song always when I'm on
a road trip by myself and I'm like,
um,
because I had all the right notes
when it's just an audience of me,
but I dance,
I dance all the time.
So like in supermarkets and conferences
and things like that, just, yeah,
inadvertently even sometimes.
I'm like, what? That's awesome.
Thanks for asking. I was totally
rooting for you with your employer,
the month video and I was curious if
he actually won employee of the month.
Beautiful. Yeah. Okay. So again, my,
my intention with,
with doing these videos was to
actually get to know my colleagues,
engage them in a playful manner and
tick things off the boxes of my job.
And what happened was, and you know,
I've received that feedback of like,
you're not a good hire, Tonya Katon
get rid of her a lot of lot. Um,
I got an email and you do you
ever get that ominous email?
That's everyone all employees
meet in the boardroom.
I received an email from HR that
was that. And I was like, oh my God.
And so I kind of like slowly walked in,
I walked in the room,
everybody was seated there
and very like stiff. And um,
all of a sudden the head of HR said,
Tanya,
we'd like to present you with something
and a video camera comes up and they
present me with this big plaque
that says, oh, most employee.
And, and to me that's the best
metric for succeeding, you know,
is that not only are they connecting to,
but they're also engaging
in play and creativity.
So that was a really wonderful
moment. Thank you for asking. Yeah.
Well,
thank you so much for having me.
Appreciate it.